welcome to this video playing shoe
Shanghai and from China and let me try
to remember i played him a number of
times with black did we have we had this
ok now we get something entirely
different that that much is clear
then we get this very wiki 5 stuff um
yeah okay I probably have I will have
really forgot now it is working after
you five I can do 98 or I can take on d5
let no that's not that dangerous i
believe but i have forgotten have fisher
basics no not clear but okay i can i can
certainly play that it's not like this
is any bad
hmm the really Nocturne ative to taking
on a six yeah there is but I can just
take care right should think so maybe
you can take with the bishop yeah okay
it's not really measuring much should be
okay in any case you know here we have
ton of trades which is really favorable
for blackjack and not like like it's
much better but in general those traits
favor black and then in the Benoni
structure that we have um I wonder if I
should play a five here or not try to
break this up immediately this also
checks here but ok let's not waste so
much time put the note in the right
direction to e5 really don't know if f4
is any good it also weakens eve form
you
I wonder how to continue though Queen f6
may be intending nights you form
something like that maybe rook b6 yeah
he's really pushing it's a that
certainly sharp but is it good I really
don't know try to go to f6 your queen 85
now maybe fall for some pinning here
and possibly 9f six back some yeah II 5i
can take on d5 so this uh this shouldn't
be a big problem v5 I think on blue one
then e five then d5 yeah that's that's
the most precise one so we cannot play
five okay so it says in his ideas that
you will take he will take on on d6 at
the end 9525 quincy three and he takes
on d6 which is equal material but that's
but a little bit problematic definitely
so
takes takes Knight takes Queen d5 Quincy
3m I'm killed on f7 so so do i do I have
to go back maybe maybe ye 69 f 6 mmm I
e5 was little strong to take and play if
I've probably now plate this guy I've
played this guy before his tactically
good but make some some strategically
dubious decisions once in a while so am
ii five was strong
so
tween here no Brooke before maybe or is
then it seven deadly maybe okay make
some makes them look Jim that's very
tough to play this is Pawn only
successor is a problem Queen before
there's always root be one like queen
before d4 could be an idea but the rupee
one this was even possible now that I
think of it maybe well then Queen a form
tough
and tending to take them okay
time warning
pi that sets not easy
I have no active idea here this is the
problem check this was lucky but it
still feels still feels like a tricky
position yeah shallots LSATs very very
difficult stuff now you can take on c5
and Jack didn't see that check me wow
that was super lucky night c5 was just
winning yeah this was an up-and-down
game I mean here here i'm probably
busted and then he blundered his queen
after which i should win but he those
pawns they they are they are tricky i
should take it six probably and not
allow seven this is fields yeah i have
20 seconds i really didn't know what to
do but night see file isn't isn't 95 the
checkmate i was thinking should being
made i can go back okay i can go back
poor ok and here again i can go back
yeah I don't know but this is this is
made fortunately this was the maid and
again eight and this is also generate I
super tough game I mean here I'm
outplayed this this if I've move was
very strong under this particular
circumstance
and the problem was that i was always
relying on this tactic but this is a
very problematic situation I can you can
take here and ah this is very dangerous
my back rank and everything this is the
compass on + 14 wide and it was very
strong Luke takes piayed so maybe this
this whole thing wasn't so great to go
to to go to g4 well or queen 85 yeah
then probably crenate five should be
improved upon okay the comp actually
gives like a good game with this move oh
yeah I'm very very very very difficult
sadly this should be okay really look
like I don't think compass on 0000 maybe
just 97 is the easiest solution also
aiming for have six but not exposing the
the night to any buttock before intend a
group d phi so this is nice actually
yeah well I didn't see this this precise
order of moves and here I'm I'm really
an in some day in some trouble I think
that the the engine is yeah I know it
it's it of course he's more than I do
but it gives a white 0.6 and it feels
like more yeah it was a it was a tough
win thanks for watching